heads up everybody there's gonna be
Japanese pronunciations in this one I'm
not Japanese I don't always get it 100%
right
I do try though let's get into it on
March the 20th 1995 five members of
Japan's own shim Rico cult boarded the
Tokyo subway in the middle of rush hour
at 8:00 a.m. they punctured bags of
sarin releasing a deadly cloud of nerve
gas into the crowded trains commuters
were blinded wracked with spasms some
choked to death on their own blood
trapped underground with no ax to run
some 6,000 people were gassed that
bright spring day and 13 of them died
the attack was ordered by ohms founder
yoga instructor Shoko Asahara a blind
mr. Kasahara had leveraged his intense
personal charisma into massive wealth
creating a religious Empire worth a
billion dollars but where most
evangelists use their money to build
churches
Asahara used his to build an army under
his watch on stockpiled chemical weapons
they bred deadly viruses they
infiltrated Japanese authorities
purchasing attack helicopters building
weapons of mass destruction and drawing
up plans to destroy the world
they were the single most ambitious cult
that has ever existed and they committed
all of their crimes while hiding in
plain sight in the video today the
remarkable story of the man who nearly
brought about Armageddon one of the
overriding features of these videos is
just how many of our subjects come from
humble circumstances Shaka Asahara he
was born no difference born in the
Kumamoto Prefecture Iran March the 2nd
1955 he was one of just nine children
that his poor mother bore poor in this
case does have a double meaning aside
from all that childbirth they were
totally broke all of their income came
from their dad's part-time work as a
traditional weaver which was barely
enough to support one men let alone a
large family but Asahara at this point
still known by his birth name chiso
Matsumoto he adds an additional
disadvantage he was blind one eyes
vision was completely gone while the
others was impaired shipped off to a
state-run school
the blinds it's only six years old the
young boy seemed destined by fate for
hardship only fate hadn't counted on one
thing asahara's charisma ferociously
intelligent Asahara was noted by his
teachers for the almost demagogic sway
that he had over other students his
voice was like a weapon but there was
something else that his teachers noted -
ah Sahara had a violent side hurting
others it was something of a Games in
once a Sahara had decided you were the
enemy he would do everything in his
power to make you suffer despite these
early warnings though Shaka graduated in
1975 with all the trappings of a deeply
ordinary man he failed the tests to get
into law and medical school and settled
for studying acupuncture relocating to
Chiba Prefecture just south of Tokyo he
opened his own practice selling quack
medicines and that was kind of it at
least for a few years in 1978 Asahara
married his sweetheart Tom Hawkins the
two settled down to making babies even
asahara's conviction in 1982 for selling
fake cures couldn't shake how
fundamentally boring his life was
however things were about to get very
very interesting in the early 1980s
Japan's economy had become the single
biggest on earth with this expansion
came a tidal wave of soulless
consumerism the result of this was a
generation of Japanese desperate to
locate some meaning in their lives so
beginning around 1980 a whole load of
new religion started cropping up sue
feed the wealthy nations impoverish
souls and one of these was Aegon Shu a
mixture of Buddhism and Hinduism Aegon
shoe had been around since 1954 but its
popularity exploded when the government
recognized it as an official religion in
1981 like thousands of others shock or
sorrow was sucked in by its teachings
becoming a devout member but rather than
gaining enlightenment
Asahara gained something even better he
got an idea
like an American robber baron watching
the first piece of railroad track being
laid asara Divine's that new religions
were the future and well he wanted a
piece of the action
so he left a GaN shoe he engineered a
spiritual crisis that allowed him to
abandon tamaco ins their children and go
to India for two years to study
religious texts when he finally returned
in 1984
was ready in September that year Asahara
founded on shinsen no KY quickly renamed
on Shinrikyo he changed his name to
Shoko Asahara and began handing out
leaflets on tokyo street corners and
preaching his new religion so there's a
blind man on a corner shouting about God
surely the busy people of Tokyo would
have just laughed at him and walked on
right well not exactly
do you remember that shock yeah Sahara
was one of the most charismatic talkers
ever born a guy who could even give
Hitler a run for his money
and like Hitler he soon put his
god-given gift to diabolical use
so at this point we need to ask
ourselves what what was on Shinrikyo
when what did they believe well it's
actually kind of hard to say now
officially the religion was a mix of
Christianity end-times theology Hindu
creation myths Buddhism yoga Nostradamus
prophecies
well apparently whatever else Asahara
had lying around unofficially though um
had one tenet making a Sahara King as
devised by a Sahara armed structure was
designed to make him rich while quickly
and effectively brainwashing everyone
that the cults got its claws into like
Scientology at force members to pay for
access to higher spiritual plane often
making people sign over their entire
fortunes
unlike Scientology had also put its
devotees through extreme pain designed
to break their will on rituals they
arranged on a scale of just plain nuts
to holy hell what the hell is going on
followers were made to drink asahara's
blood and dirty bathwater they underwent
ordeals of being plunged into boiling
water to purify their souls a practice
that led to many burns and even one
death some were locked up in isolation
rooms for days on end
others were force-fed hallucinogenic
drugs above all this floated the specter
of uh Sahara
sometimes literally followers believed
he could levitate for hours at a time
and that he was capable of reading their
minds they revered him as a living God a
reincarnation of Christ Buddha and the
Hindu god of destruction Lord Shiva all
rolled into some sort of super god-given
now utterly bizarre all of this is you
might expect to hear that alma tracted a
few hundred loonies are best but oh boy
would you be wrong Asahara he was a
gifted advertiser he recruited only from
the upper-middle classes of Japanese
society targeting the well-qualified and
rich giving on the aura of an exclusive
club albeit one that would rob you blind
as um grew richer its reach increased
sucking in more of the young and
alienated it helps that 1986 mark to the
start of the bubble economy when Japan
became phenomenally wealthy not that
home was confined to Japan influential
Russians began to join as the decades
dragged on even Germans were recruited
into an American branch opened by the
late 1980s
was perhaps the biggest of Japan's new
religions Asahara was surrounded by
10,000 devoted followers on compounds
that sprawled outside of Tokyo and in
skyscrapers rented downtown Howard Lee
he told the public he was a new guru
spreading a peaceful message in private
he told his confidence that one day he
would be the king of Japan as his
influence grew asahara's bullying ways
they returned he started forcing all
members to practice extortion and even
kidnapping their own relatives for
ransom money this money was laundered
through a network of yoga centers and
computer shops that the group
established with the help of the Yakuza
in 1989 the Tokyo Metropolitan
government it finally granted the
religion legal status even as Asahara
began preaching anti-semitic conspiracy
theories and saying Americans must be
killed some said that all that
infiltrated the government itself
bending the law to its will as the Sun
set on Japan's most hedonistic a decade
Asahara was in a pretty good place he
was rich with the religion worth a cool
1 billion American dollars
he was also worshipped by thousands of
people but that wasn't enough for the
poor boy from Kumamoto Prefecture he
wanted to rule Millions and he didn't
care if he had to kill to make his
squalid dreams come true
it started with her eyes at 11 p.m. on
June the 27th of 1994 Yoshiyuki Kono's
wife began complaining of vision
problems
the coners were a typical Japanese
upper-middle class couple living in the
leafy akechi heights suburb of Matsumoto
surrounded by doctors and lawyers and
judges that fateful night though these
security of their expensive neighborhood
it didn't save them barely had Yoshiyuki
gone to check on his wife then she fell
to the ground suffering spasms and
foaming at the mouth as the salesman
panicked little did he know that all
across their street others were
collapsing to dying before their loved
ones eyes in all that commotion no one
noticed the van driving quietly away the
van was registered to UM chin Riccio
this van Asahara had ordered modified to
emit clouds of deadly nerve gas the 1994
Matsumoto incident killed 8 people and
left 500 injured it was the first major
terrorist action biome and the first
terrorist attack ever carried out with
sarin but it didn't come from nowhere
over the last half decade um had
metamorphosed from a mere doomsday cult
into one of the most dangerous terrorist
organizations on earth the Ross had
started back in 1989 just as Tokyo was
recognizing it as an official religion
that February a young man named Shoji
Taguchi had tried to leave the cult
rather than let him go Asahara had
ordered him strangled to death
not long after relatives of all members
had banded together to file a police
complaint a young lawyer named Tsutsumi
Sakamoto took the case only to disappear
in November along with his wife and the
newborn baby and later emerged that all
members had beaten all three of them to
death and buried their bodies in a
forest when police investigated or
sympathizers on the force destroyed
evidence that could have convicted
Asahara by now Asahara was on his way to
becoming a Japanese Charles Manson
complete with a dodgy beard and haircut
but one event was about to send him
further into murderous insanity that
even Manson could have only dreamed of
[Music]
in February 1990 Japan went to the polls
to elect a new governments Asahara made
sure 24 own members were on the ballot
this would be the first step in his plan
to become king one Psalm attended the
Japanese dired that be no stopping them
there was just one tragic flaw with this
the public did not like on Shinrikyo one
little bit when the results came in ohms
24 candidates had scraped together a
lousy 1,700 votes given BOM had nearly
ten times as many adherents this was a
seriously pathetic outcome overnight
Asahara became the laughingstock of
tokyo now in an ideal world this is
where asahara's story would end but
here's the thing about laughingstocks
humiliating them it's rarely the ends as
the often misattributed quote goes first
they ignore you then they laugh at you
then they fight you then you win and
with his dreams of being king shattered
Asahara it was now ready to fight he
started by modifying his prophecies he
now told followers the world would end
following a chemical weapon attack in
1995 a fair job well that was to make
that attack happen so um change tack
they began using members who worked in
government labs to stockpile botulism
and anthrax they sent a team to Zaire
now the Democratic Republic of the Congo
- collected bola they started selling
illegal drugs to fund their activities
hiring the Yakuza to provide the muscle
within two months of the elections all
launched their first attack using their
modified van the group released botulism
into the air outside of the Japanese
diet the attack failed because they used
a harmless strain pattern that would
repeat two years later when they tried
to spray anthrax over Tokyo from the top
of skyscraper
unfortunately the same couldn't be said
for their experiments with sarin back in
Chi Chi hides Yoshioka kono called the
police begging them to save his wife
instead they arrested him and charged
him with using serrand killers neighbors
we can only imagine how a Sahara must
have laughed to himself when he heard
the news it was 1994 and own seemed
invincible
[Music]
in the nine months between the Matsumoto
incidents and the Tokyo subway attack
ohm went certifiably insane by now the
group was convinced doomsday was mere
months away that the world was out to
get them and that they needed to act
fast to bring about the apocalypse the
tails of that time are so crazy that
that seemed like fantasy if we didn't
know that they were true there's the way
arm set up his own factory dedicated to
producing ak-47s the way they managed to
steal plans for constructing tanks and
heavy artillery from a military
contractor the way they successfully
smuggled an attack helicopter into Japan
from Russia as his army and firepower
grew so did asahara's boldness in late
1994 he ordered the assassination of an
ex cultist with VX the same chemical
weapon used by North Korea to
assassinate Kim Jong Un's dissident
brother in 2017 in February 1995 he had
at Japanese official kidnapped and
incinerated alive in a specially built
oven
that same month II ordered his troops to
Samara Lee executed nine old members he
suspected of disloyalty all nine were
hanged and cremated with the ashes being
thrown in a lake and believe me it gets
even crazier in 1993 almond purchased a
ranch in Australia that was home to a
uranium mine by 1994 they were actively
planning to extract the uranium and
build a dirty bomb there's even some
evidence the cult plan to attack New
York's World Trade Center in short ohm
in early 1995 was a military fighting
force prepared to do battle and die for
their leader with Japanese authorities
still turning a blind eye to the group
they could probably have carried out any
number of atrocities that Asahara hadn't
forgotten his prophecy he'd said five
days ago that the world would end with
chemical weapons and how to make it
happen now on their Australian ranch
cultists for home had been testing
increasingly deadly types of sarin on
sheep as production moved to their
Japanese compounds the group now had
enough of the Nazi nerve gas to kill
millions of people they just needed
somewhere to release it to bring about
the apocalypse and that somewhere was of
course the Tokyo subway in March 1995
Asahara took five of his followers aside
as Kenichi hero si Toro Toyota Masato
Yokohama
Yasuo Hayashi and Takuya IU
listened attentively that master spelled
out his grand plan in a few days time
all within the world and they would have
the honor of being a Sahara's five
Horsemen of the Apocalypse at 7:30 a.m.
on March the 20th 1995 30 year-old
Kenichi Hiroshi got on board the Tokyo
subway as Mara new tree line headed for
Sachi G station a shy young man with the
dorky pair of glasses and an umbrella
clutched in one hands no one paid any
attention to him as he took a seat and
placed a plastic bag on the floor
shortly before 8 a.m. as the train
entered the government districts Hiroshi
calmly tapped his umbrella twice
puncturing his plastic bag he got up and
exited vanishing into the morning muscle
just another face in the anonymous Tokyo
crowd across the subway network Toyota
Yokoyama runs the two Ayesha's were
doing the exact same thing it never even
occurred to anyone to stop them a zero
cease train lurched off to its next
destination someone noticed a funny
smell a chemical whiff as the train
rolled on commuters trapped inside began
to feel ill to notice their vision going
funny by the time it pulled into the
next station it was clear that something
was seriously wrong as 802 a.m. the
first alarm went up on the heavier line
train poisoned by yeah so how you see
people were vomiting blood others were
having fits as the news of the problem
reached the subway authorities they made
a fateful decision they decided to shut
down the affected Lions
the result was sarin filled trains
becoming stuck between stations the
people on board trapped like rats in a
deadly box as the gas seeps out to fill
first cars then trains
hundreds of people were poisons and then
thousands with nowhere to run survivors
panicked desperately trying to escape
death in those black and claustrophobic
tunnels at one station three subway
employees bravely tried to remove a
sarin package by hands within minutes
two of them were dead as commuters ran
for the surface they brought the sarin
with them it clinging to their clothes
like a disease that spread from person
to person poisoning thousands more
bodies piled up in the streets outside
of stations paramedics who ran to treat
the wounded were themselves effectives
their nervous systems attacked by an
invisible killer in that morning's
carnival of Horrors many would go blind
many would suffer brain damage
and then he would die it was the
bloodiest day Japan's capital had awoken
- since the firebombing of Tokyo in 1945
at that moment it must have really
seemed like the end of the world had
truly arrived
luckily how suhara he had already sown
the seeds of his own downfall world
remember that whole Matsumoto incident
from about five minutes ago when on
poison that entire suburb with sarin
well Hiroshi Morita had been on the
frontlines treating that attack and had
since become Japan's leading authority
on sarin poisoning when news broke from
Tokyo about a mysterious gas poisoning
commuters he immediately but two and two
together with frightening speed he
frantically called and faxed every
single hospital in Tokyo sending them
detailed instructions for treating sarin
poisoning since Aaron can take hours to
kill or disable you it's thought
Morita's actions saved many lives but
not all of them by the time the Sun set
on Japan's day of terror twelve people
were dead dozens have been permanently
disabled and somewhere in the region of
six thousand people had been poisoned
ten years after the attack it would be
estimated that around thirty percent of
those injured were still suffering with
the effects of sarin poisoning one study
claimed that 60% of those gassed
experienced permanent eye damage for
Japanese authorities the Tokyo subway
attack it was a wake-up call there was
no longer any doubt that armed were
involved and no amount of friends in the
police could save Asahara now it was
time to take down the cultist
[Music]
the days after Ulm sarin attack were
like living through a dream less than 48
hours after Kenichi heroes II punctured
his bag of sarin a series of coordinated
police raids saw Ulm compounds raided
and 200 cultists arrested facilities for
producing sarin mustard gas anthrax and
VX were seized along with enough weapons
to start a war shocked by the southern
police attention the cult hit back hard
on March 30th the head of the National
Police Agency was shot and nearly killed
by an ohm assassin
two weeks later sympathizers released a
cloud of Austrian gas at Yokohama
station injuring 400 people but it
wasn't until May the fifth that um
really tried to get their revenge that
morning a cyanide bomb was left below
air ducts in San juku station there was
enough gas in it to kill 20,000 people
through sheer fluke the detonator
malfunctioned and it wouldn't be Tokyo's
last near miss on May the 16th 1995
Shaka asahara was finally found hiding
inside a fake wall in Homs headquarters
although he was arrested the attacks
didn't stop his 13 year old daughter
Rika was made leader and instituted a
reign of shocking abuse and torture that
surpassed even a father that same
evening and on that a bomb nearly killed
the governor of Tokyo finally on July
the 4th 1995 not four months after the
subway attack homes last gasp became
four hydrogen cyanide bombs were left in
subway stations across Tokyo together
they would have killed somewhere in the
region of a hundred thousand people but
once again those detonators failed
broken by repeated raids their teenage
dictator now taken into care on
scattered the groups high-ranking
members they all went on the run
scattering to the four winds
the last fugitive member wouldn't be
captured until 2012 Ferrara though it
was the end of the line his trial began
in 1996 just as the once rich arm
declared bankruptcy it lasted an
incredible eight years for the first
four years Asahara disrupted proceedings
by making long rambling speeches
claiming a miracle would save him that's
even as legendary charisma it couldn't
help him now in 2000 a sahara seemed to
recognize this and he fell silent he
wouldn't speak again for the rest of his
life in 2004 Asahara was finally
sentenced to death by hanging
his lawyers failed to file appeals and
in
2006 the sentence was upheld not two
years later Asahara had a sort of mental
collapse he stopped all contact with his
family and followers he stopped eating
and less he was spoon-fed
he refused to use the toilet and instead
took to wearing an adult diaper soiling
himself in silence in a gloomy corner of
his cell defeated and forgotten
he stayed like that for the next decade
on July the 6th 2018 guards led Asahara
from his cell out into the yard
alongside six other armed cultists who
he hadn't seen for 12 years it's
impossible to know what the other
cultists felt seeing him in that moment
seeing the man who'd once bend them and
half of Tokyo to his will reduced to a
silent living corpse did they feel
remorse did they see him for the false
gods that he always was we'll never know
all seven were hangs that morning their
families only alert us after they were
already dead
they were cremated inside the prison
their bodies burned as that once burned
those of their victims when news of
asahara's death reached the media most
living outside of Japan kind of just
shrugged and were like who yes even now
his story it might not be over in 2000
just as a Sahara was falling into his
catatonic state all officially renounced
him breaking into two offshoots the
majority renamed themselves a leaf they
set up a fund to compensate arms victims
and s'more to become peaceful but they
never completely succeeded in exercising
Asahara today there are around 1,500
aleef members journalists report that
many still live surrounded by a Sahara's
teachings reading his books and
decorating their homes with portraits of
him although under surveillance by
Japanese authorities they continue to
worship the cultists who tried to
destroy the world and they're not alone
in 2016 the tiny European nation of
Montenegro expelled 58 foreigners
suspected of being members of own
although four were Japanese the majority
were Russians that same year Russian
authorities busted 25 compounds operated
by the group prosecutors have warned
that there may be up to 30,000 russians
currently involved with the cult the BBC
has since reported the group operating
in belarus and ukraine
Shoko Asahara may be dead but his
influence it clearly remains while
there's no evidence his remaining
followers are planning more terrorist
atrocities they still worship the man
who once brought Tokyo
to its knees for a man as charismatic as
Asahara it seems his dark legacy extends
even beyond the grave so I really hope
you found that video interesting
hopefully we answered that big hoo
question for you if you did please do
give us a thumbs up below and don't
forget to subscribe we got brand new
videos several times a week so hit that
subscribe us and hit the notification
bell so you'd learn about all of those
if you want something more right now
though videos linked to on the screen
now from the archives and as always
thank you for watching
you